[Música]
el día de la visibilidad lésbica nació
en españa en el año 2008 tras las
acciones del movimiento lgtb que buscaba
y busca visibilizar a todas las mujeres
que tienen derecho a vivir y ocupar
espacios que sean igualitarios y donde
no exista ningún tipo la discriminación
en muchas partes del mundo de las bicis
la diversidad sexual es aceptada sin
embargo todavía existen culturas donde
las creencias también los estigmas y
prejuicios
priman por esta razón muchas personas
tienen que vivir condenadas con esta
discriminación reprochable por supuesto
hoy resulta fundamental educar a la
sociedad en general sobre lo que
significa hacer y sentir de una forma
diferente y aprender a respetar y a
valorar a las personas sin importar su
raza su religión y también su
preferencia sexual no hay que olvidar a
las mujeres que han sido víctimas de la
lesbofobia que han perdido la vida a
manos de grupos y personas violentas y
que no toleran la diversidad sexual para
ello entonces quiero saludar en este
momento a nuestras dos invitadas del día
ellas son margarita salas activistas
lgtb y expresidenta del partido vamos y
su esposa la primera mujer en recibir la
nacionalidad costarricense por
matrimonio igualitario estamos hablando
de iguana espitia su tachan activista el
gbc y gracias a de margarita y liana por
estar con nosotros en este espacio
france24 directo américa un gusto
hola buenos días muchas gracias por el
hábito de hacer para conversar así es
margarita quiero empezar contigo
preguntándote la importancia de este día
de la visibilidad lésbica
es fundamental porque lo que no se
nombra no existe y como las lesbianas
muchas veces somos invisibilizadas por
junto con ellos y quedan de lado las
necesidades las experiencias y las
realidades nuestras como mujeres es
importante que entendamos que las
lesbianas también somos mujeres y por
ende enfrentamos mucha de la misoginia
presente en la sociedad ahora margarita
porque también pues digamos dentro del
colectivo lgtb
digamos como una persona trans o una
persona homosexual son más visibles que
las lesbianas dentro de igual este mismo
colectivo por qué pasa esto
bueno en el caso digamos en relación con
los hombres gays pienso que opera mucho
lo que es el machismo el machismo y el
desprecio por lo femenino que está
presente también dentro de cualquier
espacio también dentro de la población
el g20 y comas y en relación a la
población trans bueno es una población
que vive en este momento es una
discriminación y mucho más visible en
relaciones la entidad pero es importante
que recordemos que también hay mujeres
trans lesbianas es importante que
estamos hablando dos cosas para
orientación sexual identidad de género
entonces muy importante visibilizar la
diversidad de orientaciones sexuales que
existen a lo largo de diferentes
identidades también margarit iliana cómo
es vivir siendo una mujer lesbiana en
américa latina en cuestión de derechos
también estamos hablando la
discriminación la atención pública la
conversamos con más romeros a la la
encargada de salud de directo américa
esta discriminación sobre todo en algo
tan importante para la mujer como una
consulta en el ginecólogo
pues es una realidad que está sucediendo
que tristemente continúa sucediendo así
como lo mencionaba en la nota anterior
sin embargo creo que cada vez se abren
más espacios para reconocer la vida y
las formas de vivir propias de las
mujeres lesbianas y para eso creo que es
muy importante
darle visibilidad a los movimientos y
activismo sociales que se llevan a cabo
desde las diferentes organizaciones
para hacer la exigibilidad de que los
gobiernos se hagan cargo de garantizar
una vida plena pero además también como
nos apersonamos nosotras mismas de
nuestros derechos y nos hacemos visibles
a través de los diferentes espacios en
los que podemos estar creo que toda esta
pues intolerancia a la diferencia a la
diversidad sexuales se debe a la
educación
creo que con mejores políticas de
educación en nuestro continente a lo
mejor se puede hacer un mundo más
inclusivo un mundo más tolerante
claro la educación es clave en esto y
por eso es fundamental que los programas
de educación para la sexualidad integral
continúen en los países donde ya existen
y se empiecen a implementar es es
importante acá aclarar que hay
diferencias enormes entre los países en
américa latina y el caribe por ejemplo
hablemos de la región centroamericana
dentro de centroamérica son pocos los
países que han dado pasos para legalizar
siquiera el reconocimiento de las
uniones entre parejas del mismo sexo
para contar con leyes antidiscriminación
o para tener educación sexual integral
en escuelas y colegios pero es un cambio
más amplio es un cambio cultural de la
sociedad en su conjunto que vamos a
empezar a ver lo vamos ver más
personajes más narrativas en cine en
radio en televisión ocupamos que las
figuras públicas se manifiesten que los
estados tengan cero tolerancia con las
agresiones porque conforme se van
haciendo avances en derechos también
vemos un ataque de vuelta y en esos días
hemos visto en en colombia también
verdad ataques hacia personas en razón
de su orientación sexual y en toda
américa latina' seguimos viendo
asesinato eres en razón de su
orientación sexual es muy importante
saber que las mujeres lesbianas
enfrentamos discriminación en diferentes
frentes y últimamente también mucho las
parejas les maternales están enfrentando
dificultades donde los estados intentan
quitarle a sus hijos intentan intervenir
en la crianza de estos niños y bien esto
es muy importante que el sistema
educativo pero que la sociedad su
conjunto del sistema de salud todas
nuestras entidades puedan proteger los
derechos de las personas
independientemente de nuestro
orientación sexual o identidad de género
usted habla un punto también muy
importante las parejas de mujeres
lesbianas que tienen una familia que
tiene hijos que tienen hijos que tan
difícil es pues tener una familia
realmente constituida en un país
latinoamericano pues que teniendo hijos
que nos faltan las leyes que protejan
realmente a estas familias como
cualquier otra
yo creo que es importante señalar aquí
que las familias es decir hay familias
que están conformadas exclusivamente por
dos personas adultas como nosotras
nosotras somos por la familia entonces
primero es el reconocimiento social a
que las familias no necesariamente
implica tener hijos ellos por un lado
pero por otro lado hay ciertos avances
que se están haciendo a nivel de la
región donde se reconoce plenamente el
derecho de las dos personas para crear a
los niños ya las niñas entonces ahí creo
que es importante cómo reconocer cuáles
son los avances que se han dado lo que
pasó en costa rica hace un par de años
con el reconocimiento del matrimonio y
por ende el reconocimiento de las
maternidades lo que está pasando en
chile lo que está pasando en colombia
hace bastantes años también hay todo un
avance pero no es parejo no es en toda
la región no podemos y vamos a hablar de
la región en una de una sola de una sola
mirada y en cualquier forma hay una
distancia también entre lo que sucede
entre el centro y la periferia de cada
uno de los lugares no pasa lo mismo con
pareja para compararle algo maternales
en bogotá a lo que puede pasar en un
municipio distante de la ciudad no y
también e iliana como usted
también una cosa es la ley y otra muy
diferente es que se cumpla la ley porque
todo se ve muy bien en el papel pero a
la hora de hacer valer sus derechos pues
ahí hay un largo trecho no por supuesto
pero sin ley no hay posibilidad hemos
dicho la ley ayuda a abrirla el paso
pero desde desde la ley es necesario
comenzar por la ley para luego hacer las
transformaciones en adelante y que haya
mucha capacitación al funcionariado
público es importante que entendamos que
muchas de estas temáticas son nuevas las
personas cuando cuando crecieron cuando
se capacitarán cuando estudiaron si es
que lo hicieron no era esto parte de lo
que discutía entonces la capacitación al
funcionario al público es central y aquí
estamos enfrentando ataques de grupos
anti derechos que buscan bloquear la
capacitación en el funcionariado público
e introduciendo en barreras y alegando
objeción de conciencia' algunos casos u
otros elementos en distractores es muy
importante entender que el funcionario
público tiene el mandato de implementar
desde una perspectiva de derechos
humanos la protección de los derechos de
todas las personas en todos nuestros
ojalá todos nuestros países puedan
continuar avanzando en esos frentes de
manera simultánea aprobando la
legislación que proteja los derechos
humanos de las personas elegir temas y
desarrollando educación para la
sexualidad campañas de capacitación y
sensibilización y capacitando el
funcionariado público todo eso tiene que
ir avanzando de la mano